un couple et leur ami accusé d'avoir
séquestré et torturé des jeunes filles
dans un pavillon d'apoignny en 1984 sont
actuellement jugé devant la Cour
d'Assise
d'osser secrétaire général de
l'Association pour adultes et jeunes
handicapés il aurait violé régulièrement
depuis 1 an une jeune handicapée mentale
de 23
ans un pêcheur a découvert ce matin dans
Lyonne à osser le cadavre entièrement
dénudé d'une jeune Anglaise de 20
ans bonsoir affaire douloureusees
difficile à tente pour une famille la
disparition d'Isabelle Laville âgée de
17 ans près docer est toujours
inexpliqué depuis une dizaine d'années
quatre jeunes filles déficientes
mentales ayant transité par cette
institution restent toujours porté
disparu peut-on continuer à cautionner
par notre silence cette
situation